it's gonna be sixto sanchez making his
major league debut
he'll uh pitch in the second game of a
double header this may very well be
the most anticipated marlins pitching
debut since the day we saw jose
fernandez for the first time
in the first game he chops this one that
is vr at short on the backhand and
dug out at first by logan forsyth the
nice defensive play behind six
though that one fouled off
at 100 miles an hour
oh six toe can field his position how
about that a couple of pitches in that
ab at 100.
and that pitch is strike three called on
as drupal cabrera and there's the first
major league strikeout for six doe
sanchez and here he goes will crow
three years in the minor leagues 57
games 56 starts welcome
to the bigs hot shot could be two
turner garcia comes across the bag but
sierra flying down the line that would
have had to happen real quickly
and he gets a pop-up short center ball
in the air a long time and
with the roblox there in plenty of time
very important
second out swing and a miss on the curve
with his first major league strikeout
major league debut
of sixto sanchez going out and executing
it and that is just absolutely filthy
2-0 pulled on the ground to the first
baseman to make the play by himself
and a very quick and easy one two three
seconds
top of the third gomes robles and turner
john gomes is this number 101
c u later
and the nets are on top and john gomes
has a
seven-game hitting streak harrison
overlaps he's out at his second base
position with garcia
between him and thames delayed steal
throw to second on target out vr
tried to surprise the nats gomes from
his knees
that went 2-5 on the caught stealing you
can't fool young gums he just hit a
tater man
he's locked in watch the shuffle shuffle
go
trying to catch the catcher sleeping and
from his knees john gomez throws a seed
to josh harrison covering
they've got lead off man on all three
innings here's corey dickerson
corey dickerson with a drive out to
right center
field this one is gonna go a long home
run
for corey dickerson and the marlins take
the lead
big time home run 438 feet
i would wonder want to get your thoughts
you can kind of control it a little bit
more this one off the glove the glove
comes off
and vr makes the play i mean it's just
as simple as that
a little bit like the base hit of course
a little higher hop
the gloves are off two balls and two
strikes to thames
well there it is again just unbelievable
movement his third strikeout
so the bases are loaded two outs marlins
leading 2-1 bottom of the fourth three
and two they'll start the merry-go-round
and he chased it but it gets away from
gomes
and two runs are going to score
on 3-2 the marlins were off with the
pitch no reason to stop for the speedy
john bertie
yeah the national the nationals caught a
break because the ball left the field of
play
so john birdie has to go back to third
base
oh two that one's slow rollers shortstop
turner tough time getting it out of his
glove won't have a throw
marlins make it 4-1 transition
from cervelli to alfaro halfway through
the outing
and for as great as the fastball has
been that change-up is moving
all over the place that's his fourth
strikeout you know he's messing guys up
i mean everybody's
talking about how hard he's throwing
i mean look at the swings they're
awkward they're unsure of what they're
seeing i mean
these are some hot hitters too mind you
get you a good one and let it rip
he did see you
later
for a hitter that was a real good one
and then answer back to within a run on
victor roble's rocket
his second of the year for the marlins
base is loaded one out here in the fifth
now on 3-2 he hits one in the air toward
left center
soto gets ahead of steam up with it here
comes
anderson pro is a little off the mark
it'll be a sacrifice fly for john bertie
and the marlins get a little insurance
it's five to three
two one and two out tying runs aboard
and gomes who has two hits in this game
coming to the plate
and gomes with the drive out to left
there will be
enough room for louis brinson to make
the catch
stands right now six doe sanchez in line
for his first major league
win but there will be more drama
that's a ground ball and it's forsyth to
step
on the bag it's a marlins win it's a
six-toe win
the first of his major league career and
the marlins have a 5-3 win tonight